this is something really funny last
night I was browsing the david pakman
show subreddit and there was a thread
that someone made pointing out that
there should be sort of a David Pakman
show
bingo of sorts showing that there are a
few different catchphrases a sort of
drinking game or bingo of the game any
time david says says the phrase or words
gong show abortive or depraved listeners
have to take a shot and this gave me the
idea that we should actually develop
like a david pakman show bingo board I
don't know what we would do with it we
could turn it into like a thousand-piece
puzzle we could send it out as a sort of
poster print I don't know what exactly
we would do with it and the the reddit
participant is including some good ones
I think also on it would have to be if I
accidentally punch my mic that would
have to be like the center square which
sometimes happens when I get very very
impassioned about a story I think I say
vile quite a bit depraved is a good one
gong show is a good one and so is
abortive asking a live caller if they're
on speakerphone should definitely be a
box on the bingo board joking about how
infrequently I mentioned membership I
think might be something that could be
on there quite frankly is another phrase
that I tend to use a lot any number of
is of course a long time classic that
goes back a long ways but I don't know
what else should be on it right and I'm
curious to hear from the audience and I
don't even know like is a bingo board
looks like there are they 5x5 is what it
looks like from this picture so we need
25 total phrases or words I think we can
get to 20 yeah I've got a few too it's a
whole thing and then you also like to
impersonate Trump a lot yeah so many
many could be a square big Li or big
league yeah although I don't know that
it shouldn't when if I'm satirically
using someone else's catchphrase I think
that's a little dishonest for a bingo
board cuz they should really be my
phrases now that ones that I've sort of
jokingly appropriated from someone else
see if we do this you have to like tune
that out though you can't think about
the bingo board because otherwise
there'll be some like inherent bias
there yeah I know I'll be literal using
words they're choosing not to say some
words right but presumably the bingo
boards are randomized so that not
everyone has the same board
that way cuz otherwise everybody wins at
the same time right as long as they're
there paying attention so right in tell
me what other words and phrases should
should be there any number I know that
there are lots of others maybe one would
be when a hatred uses your instead of
your like you apostrophe re versus y oh
you are like that would be part of the
bingo a bingo item I'm open okay so get
in touch comment on the YouTube video
for this story comment on that reddit
thread at david pakman.com slash re d di
t email me tweet me whatever i'm gonna
start putting together a list and once
we get 25 good ones
we'll figure out something to do with
the bingo board i think it's gonna be a
stunningly good idea maybe you get a
free bingo board with a new membership
in the future or something like that